une expédition au bout du monde 1,9
spectaculaire un survivant sur une île
perdue
ça vous dirait d'entendre la véritable
histoire de robinson crusoé j'ai fait
naufrage
j'étais perdue condamnée à lutter seul
pour survivre dans un monde auquel je
n'étais pas préparée il est malgré tout
mais la voilà la solution
j'avais construit une cabane dans un
arbre
non mais c'est une blague glénat
et il me vient les collections d'été
loudun construire son nid ça nous ferait
aussi un autre citoyen nous en
débarrasser nous allons leur montrer de
quel bois dans ce sens le 20 avril
découvrez une merveilleuse histoire de
survie et de courage
robin
et d'amitié mais
bien joué mon ami alors la robinson
crusoé
pourquoi il est reparti en courant c'est
peut-être une hauteur qui me fuit le 20
avril au cinéma en 3d et en 2d